as any cat owner could probably tell you
these fuzzy fur balls spent a lot of
time grooming themselves according to
some studies up to a quarter of their
waking hours cats of sandpapery tongs
are covered in sharp little cones known
as papilla researchers wanted a closer
look at how these papillae actually help
cats groom both their outer and inner
layers of fur so that created 3d scans
of tongues from six species of cats the
domestic cat the Bobcat the Cougar Snow
Leopard tiger and lion zooming it
revealed that the papillae have a
u-shaped cavity at their tips which has
a wicking effect and helps carry
droplets of saliva through that top
layer of fur down to the cat skin the
scientists also filmed several casts
grooming when they slowed down the
footage they noticed that the cats
flared their tongues so the papillae
were perpendicular to the surface of the
tongue which maximizes how much fur they
came into contact with the researchers
also used a thermal camera and found
that depositing saliva on their skin
helps the cat's cool off if they get
overheated the researchers also designed
a hairbrush based on the shape and
configuration of the papillae on a cat's
tongue compared to a regular hair brush
the brush tug glass and was easier to
clean beyond helping humans get tangles
out of their hair or cat for another
carpets the scientists say the brush
could potentially help deliver medicine
or cleaning solution directly to cats
skin which could help improve treatments
related to cat allergies for now it's a
closer look at the surprisingly complex
everyday routine of our fuzzy feline
friends
[Music]
[Music]